HOURS AGO.
>> Bret: HE WOULDN'T ANSWER
THE QUESTION, ASKED, WILL RON
ROSENSTEIN KEEP HIS JOB?
STANDBY.
BACK TO THE PANEL.
TOM BEVAN, MOLLIE HEMINGWAY,
MIKE ALLEN.
>> MY COLLEAGUE MIKE ALLEN
CHEERFULLY SAID MUELLER IS
UNAFRAID.
IT IS WORTH REMEMBERING HE WAS
UNAFRAID WHEN HE BOTCHED THE
ANTHRAX INVESTIGATION BY
TARGETING THE WRONG PERSON.
I THINK THERE'S DEFINITELY A
BURDEN OF PROOF THAT THE FBI,
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, AND
SPECIAL COUNSEL HAVE TO MEET.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKED ABOUT
SOME OF THE CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST.
ROSENSTEIN HAS A FEW OF THEM,
NOT JUST WHEN HE WAS CITED FOR
THE LETTER RECOMMENDING THE FIRE
OF COMEY.
HE WAS PROBABLY THE GUY WHO
SIGNED OFF ON ANDREW MCCABE'S
RIDICULOUS INVESTIGATION AS TO
WHETHER SESSIONS WAS A RUSSIAN
SPY.
HE IS OVERSEEING THIS AG
INVESTIGATING FISA ABUSES OF
WHICH ROSENSTEIN WAS INVOLVED.
PLENTY OF CONFLICTS.
IT WOULD BE GOOD FOR THE MEDIA
TO BE THINKING ABOUT THEM.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL, SO MANY
DEMOCRATS, ALL THE PROBLEMS
WE'VE SEEN.
IT'S WORTH REMEMBERING CONGRESS
HAS BEEN REQUESTING TO FIND OUT
HOW DID THE INVESTIGATION INTO
RUSSIA START.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
FBI ARE STONEWALLING AND
OBSTRUCTING.
>> Bret: TODAY 3600 DOCUMENTS
GOING TO THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THEY ARE
MOVING PARTS HERE ON A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT INVESTIGATIONS OF THE
FBI AND DOJ AND OBVIOUSLY OF
WHATEVER SPECIAL COUNSEL OR
MUELLER IS LOOKING INTO.
>> THE PRESIDENT MENTIONING A
MILLION DOCUMENTS.
SO MUCH NEWS THESE DAYS.
1.4 MILLION DOCUMENTS HAVE GONE
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE TO MUELLER.
TO HIT PAUSE FOR A SECOND ON THE
AMAZING MOMENT THAT WE SAW PLAY
OUT.
THAT WILL BE PICKED OVER FOR
YEARS.
THE PRESIDENT'S BODY LANGUAGE.
LISTEN TO HIS TONE.
HIS REPETITION, USING DISGRACE,
DISGRACEFUL AGAIN AND AGAIN.
SAME TWICE WE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
JOHN ROBERTS, SO GOOD, ON WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN HE SAYS THAT ABOUT
YOU.
THE PRESIDENT FIGHTING.
IT PLAYS INTO WHAT HE'S BEEN
TRYING TO DO FOR A WHILE.
WE HAVE SEEN THE DISCREPANCY AND
HIS LAWYERS STRATEGY AND HIS.
THE LAWYERS I WANTED TO
COOPERATE.
TOLD HIM, ASSURED HIM THEY WILL
PAY OFF FOR HIM TO COOPERATE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
RESISTING.
HE'S BEEN WANTING TO FIGHT AND
THIS DOES IT BIG TIME.
>> Bret: IT'S INTERESTING TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY, AND WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT MUELLER MAY HAVE
FOUND THAT REFERRED TO THE U.S.
ATTORNEY IN NEW YORK.
BUT HAVING THE POLITICS OF ALL
OF THIS SWIRLING AROUND AT THE
SAME TIME.
MEANWHILE, THIS IS A WEEK AHEAD
OF JIM COMEY'S BOOK.
IT'S AS THESE INVESTIGATIONS ARE
GOING ON ON CAPITOL HILL.
MUELLER HAS TO KNOW HE CROSSES
THE LINE IN AT LEAST THE
PRESIDENT'S MIND IS HE'S
NEGOTIATING WITH THE PRESIDENT
TO SIT DOWN, BY DOING THIS.
YOU WONDER, HOW DO YOU GET TO
THE POINT.
>> YEAH.
THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH WAS
AMAZING.
GREATEST HITS.
HE WENT THROUGH COMEY,
HILLARY CLINTON, LIES, JEFF
SESSIONS RECUSAL, MUELLER,
ROSENSTEIN.
RECITATION OF THE GREATEST HITS.
OBVIOUSLY HE'S UPSET.
AS BRIT HUME MENTIONED, THE ONLY
CRIME WE KNOW OF THAT MIGHT BE
CONNECTED IS AN FEC VIOLATION.
OVER HERE, TRUMP STARTING WITH
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA.
AND NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT A
PRIVATE ATTORNEY OF THE
PRESIDENT AND RATED BY THE FBI.
IT'S A PRETTY DRAMATIC INCREASE
IN THE STAKES OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.